and finally new rule anyone who went
apeshit the last two weeks because I
said going through a recession would be
worth it if it undermined Trump's
popularity has to enroll in college and
take a course in perspective a recession
is a survivable event what Trump is
doing to this country is not
democracy is about to go the way of the
dinosaurs because we've been taken over
by a dodo bird so let me repeat
recessions are survivable events we
survive one every time a Republican is
in the White House every Republican
president since Teddy Roosevelt has
presided over a recession four
Republican presidents and two of them
and Eisenhower had three the United
States has survived 47 recessions at all
and since the Great Depression we've
never gone more than ten years without
one another recession is coming
not because I'm rooting for it because
someone someone passed a giant tax
giveaway to the rich that added
trillions to the debt and started a
trade war for no reason and deliberately
sabotage the Affordable Care Act and
rolled back the rules for banks so they
can once again gamble with our money
those are actual policies from men with
real power as opposed to me who just
made a wish
[Applause]
but you would never know that from the
right-wing nut a sphere where this made
me a bigger threat to our national
security than Canada Laura Ingram said
he wants an economic collapse to get rid
of Trump and I didn't say economic
collapse
I said recession for the record I'm
against reducing us to the point where
we're foraging for food and trading
[ __ ] for candles yes
[Applause]
Alex Jones tweeted Bill Maher is worth a
hundred million dollars but he says we
should crash the US economy to stop
Trump and when is he ever strayed from
the facts and then everyone on the right
said I had a hundred million dollars and
all I have to say about that is I do
[Applause]
sarah palin tweeted to her follower
[Laughter]
that I was out of touch and Wayne Allyn
root said he doesn't care if your kids
starve Mike Serna vich said suicides
increased during recessions Bill Maher
wants people to die yes
specifically Mike Serna vish
I want him to put his head in the oven
so starving kids confuse it for food no
I don't want that I don't know who the
[ __ ] you are Mike Serna [ __ ] but I want
you to live a long healthy life and get
the help you so desperately me
but this accusing me of wanting people
to starve and die is pretty rich coming
from the party that has never been shy
about actually enacting policies that
starve and kill people
taking away healthcare cutting Medicaid
and food stamps and the Children's
Health Insurance Program forcing
government shutdowns this month Journal
of the American Medical Association says
the Trump environmental agenda is likely
to cost the lives of over 80,000
Americans so there's that and I guess
those claiming that I would come out
unscathed in a recession
must have missed the episode with
Elizabeth Warren from the last recession
you know before the crash I had most of
my savings in Lehman Brothers ah I don't
have a question I just want you to hold
me
it's okay because some things are more
important than money and one of them is
living in a country that reasonably
resembles the one that existed from 1776
to 2016 in a situation this grave it is
not crazy to use economic manipulation
that's what sanctions are we pinch
countries in the pocketbook so they'll
act better just think of this as
sanctions against ourselves although
again I can't really make a recession
happen even with my hundred million
recessions happen and we always recover
but fallen Republic's don't rome fell
and they still haven't fixed that
Stadium I'm not rooting for a disaster
the disaster is already here if a
recession is what it takes to make
Donald Trump not so cute anymore then
bring it on
because seriously one of the problems
with the roaring economy is it tends to
make people put up with a bad president
it's like great sex in a bad
relationship and the sex is good all the
annoying things your partner does are
forgiven that's what we're in right now
the good sex economy
I just want America to say about Donald
Trump what everybody in a relationship
says when the hot sex wears off what the
[ __ ] am I doing with this person